this is er wanders around Berlin day and
night hunting Pokemon he's not the only
one the crazed has taken Germany by
storm and millions have downloaded the
app game is meet up all over the city in
parks or at historical sites to hunt
down virtual monsters SR goes by the
name of bullet and he's hoping to track
down his favorite Pokemon today will he
succeed
when fear the fith entertain us to
finally capture an Arcanine that's been
my primary goal since the game's release
but I just haven't got enough growlithe
he's only got three growlithe SAT the
moment and they need a lot of growlithe
candy to evolve into an Arcanine i know
mine is grounded so one of my favorites
I've already run after many of them and
almost fell flat on my face once bullet
wants to collect all 151 Pokemon both
the common ones found on nearly every
street corner and in particular the very
rare ones they often pop up where
tourists also tend to congregate in
front of Berlin's historical sites his
avatar is bullet 93 while he's moving
around in the real world the virtual
monsters crop up or spawn on his online
map he can then try to capture them by
throwing virtual balls at them Lewis F I
others also attract Pokemon to specific
areas
it also helps to have an external
battery on hand in case the phone dies
what do you bring along when you play
pokemon go on days like this you need
enough to drink I've got a full bottle
here and one that I've started I've got
some snacks and money in case I get
really hungry God the hunt continues I
sodium on Garcia's yeah as I said what's
underneath kaoru gamma dog Bo Tong this
keeps happening at the moment people
making fake cause like someone saying
there's a dragonite well not necessarily
a dragonite but maybe a dratini or a
growlithe and there's nothing in the end
maybe there really is a dratini I'm
gonna run the game has changed bullets
life there's been feeling this medal I
spend a lot more time outside I used to
hang out at home a lot unless I met
friends but now I'm fitter my stamina
has improved because of all the running
I'm spending more time in the Sun
getting town-owned do you think your
personality has changed because of the
game it's what I've always been an open
person but I've become more open I talk
with more strangers I go up to people
talk to them I never did that before
especially on when established for
anxious nigam off a huge pokemon
community has emerged in Berlin in a
matter of weeks for the Anangu rizzo
done before days ago so we caught this
dog is growlithe which had spawned here
it ran away from me a few times from you
as well but then we got it I was 3 so
this is all about growl ascona people is
reasonably to be massive
you know what yes that was a grounded
but you cheat around here astre teenies
or magic cards for me it's clearly about
brow let's have you got over your data
limit seems huh you can pick up some
tips here right you've already got an
Arcanine from growlithe that hatch from
eggs anyone who runs around a lot can do
that players can collect eggs which
hatch after specified distances have
been covered but they never know which
monster will hatch none of my ex have
ever hatched a growlithe but i did get
Kabuto so now I've got a commute ops
isn't it a bit frustrating when you
really want something and you just can't
get it don't miss this one it has been
frustrating especially when everyone
else has it and you're the only one who
reign in oneself that you don't even
have it missed half bullet has been
playing pokemon go since the day it was
released as a child he played pokemon on
a game console he plays as much as he
can
no I'm banando at the weekend I play
about 20 hours I'm fun festival
sometimes more awww c'mere he's training
to be a medical technician he still
lives at home because he can't afford
his own place yet it's been done long
the thing that people to fix myself
that's why I spend a lot of time away
from home I need time for myself my mom
keeps saying that I'm hardly ever at
home that was the case before to
understand when I finally do move out
she'll be alone anyway so she has to get
used to it thought I know then what for
this remodeling Arun 23 I should have
moved out already maybe when a rare
Pokemon spawns in other words appears on
a map players only have a few minutes to
capture it then the virtual monster
disappears again word soon gets around
if a rare Pokemon is in the vicinity was
I know busca activate bullets suddenly
disappears
there it is a growlithe the last one
good let's do what happened um yeah hum
Dalton we were hunting a dratini and an
ammonite over there and then a friend
said that there was a growlithe at the
growlers part of what I came running a
good gun unless good guns and now I've
got it
success now he's got another hunting
date elsewhere in town you may go go and
lice is calm guys boys and on that
Pokemon goes below yeah and this month
Oh
at someone's and please my endless my
night's race will come you Izzy Yanina
and bullet had been friends for a long
time they're dead this isn't es phone
okay as this dust is among your mind up
over there now he's also caught the
much-desired fire-type pokemon
Charmander but deuce Parkins actually
fly when playing pokemon go I to chai
yeah but at least it's easy to talk to
people with Pokemon go maybe I've heard
stories about people who met by a
Pokemon go and went on a date there are
some cases but not that many yeah thank
you son avena gonna have to be later
than Hindi contact my friends contact
list is full they talk about poker stops
and about what they've caught and blah
blah blah and then they swapped numbers
they get numbers from women yes
bullet and Yanina have started meeting
more regularly since they started
playing pokemon go oh okay good
do you put your phone away when you have
a break yes when I keep it on we'll have
this our whole life long because we grew
up with it I'll always be fond of
nintendo definitely we're from the
pokemon era we grew up with it if we
were 16 now we wouldn't have experienced
pokemon and wouldn't be playing and you
don't see it as a waste of time I don't
know not at all there are things that I
could do instead might learn to play an
instrument but I prefer to play this and
don't see it as time wasted it's a good
use of time for me nothing Goethe 545
bullet has almost reached his goal
acquiring an Arcanine the first I've got
50 candies so now I can evolve it
I'm so happy after all those hours here
it is finally this is my favorite
monster there it is is that if it's
endless it's their mine are and of
course I'm super happy I'm not to speak
to me to go happy what now can you stop
playing now I'd caught a hundred and
nineteen Pokemon maybe my next goal will
be to catch 130 but I don't know yet
i'll set a small goal so I hang in there
and I'm always happy when I reach it and
can set my new goes underneath the sea
the harbor so the hunt will go on but is
there any profound meaning it's been
anything that people should always
nurture the child within them regardless
of their age
that's a line from this
oh come on i'm too
even on a lot
Oh